this morning we're learning new details
of a US military operation overnight to
the site of a deadly American plane
crash in Afghanistan David Martin is at
the Pentagon Forrest David good morning
what are we learning good morning well
overnight us helicopters finally managed
to reach the crash site and recover the
bodies of the two crewmen we don't know
yet why the airplane went down but we do
know the pilot declared an in-flight
emergency shortly before the crash the
plane came down in a remote Taliban
controlled area in central Afghanistan
social media video claims to show the
wreckage of the plane with US Air Force
markings
US officials confirmed this was Obama
d-r-e 11a it's used for electronic
surveillance and can fly at high
altitudes with extended range the plane
is often referred to as quote Wi-Fi in
the sky Afghan officials say their
forces clash with the Taliban as they
tried to reach the crash site now as you
can see from the video that was a large
airplane with a crew of just two the
rest of it was crammed with
state-of-the-art technology Anthony
David Martin thanks